all right here we go a Fox News Alert
even more legal trouble for Jesse
Smollett
a grand jury in Chicago has reportedly
indicted the Empire actor on 16 felony
counts of disorderly contact conduct for
filing a false police report in the wake
of his arrest last month after police
say he alleged to pay pay two men to
help him stage a fake attack he later
claimed was a racist and homophobic
ain't crime Matt Fenn is in Chicago with
this latest chapter Matt is this 16
counts were you expecting this you know
right now we are working to
independently confirm this Brian I just
spoke to a clerk at the Cook County
Criminal Court who over the phone told
me that a grand jury did return 16
additional charges against Jesse
Smollett the courts just closed here so
unfortunately we don't have the
documentation in front of us to confirm
this but there are several news outlets
here in Chicago right now that are
reporting a grand jury just returned an
indictment with 16 additional charges
against Jessie Smollett for disorderly
conduct for filing a false police report
apparently for all of the additional
follow-up interviews and reports that
Jessie Smollett gave to officers and
detectives Smollett was originally
charged with just one felony count of
disorderly conduct for filing a false
police report for his alleged hate crime
in which he claimed president Trump
supporters beat him put a noose around
his neck and called him racial and
homophobic slurs the actor now is
apparently in much more legal trouble
this new set of charges each carries a
possible sentence of probation to four
years in prison he's already pleaded not
guilty that to that initial first charge
but he's currently free on a hundred
thousand dollar bond
Brian all right not heard from that camp
we'll have to see